every now and again anime viewers are
faced with a supposedly vital decision
will I watch this dubbed into English or
will I stick to the original Japanese
voiceover to the uninitiated this might
seem obvious or unimportant but try
telling that to the countless Forum
posts and probably the comment section
underneath this video If you were to
venture into said areas of the internet
looking for an answer too which is
better the English Dragon Ball super or
the Japanese dragon ball super you'd
quickly realize just how defensive and
elitist some members of our lovely
Community can be regarding the subject
so like the wonderful YouTuber I am it's
my job to throw fuel onto the proverbial
dumpster fire that is this topic taking
into account the first 39 episodes I
think it's finally time to discuss in
detail which is in fact better this is
Dragon Ball super English vs Japanese
small disclaimer I am not sponsored in
any way by FUNimation of course I have
my own internal biases and given the
nature of this topic subjectivity will
play a large role so by all means feel
free to tell me how wrong I am in the
comments section down below in order to
tackle this Mammoth topic for the sake
of simplicity City I've divided the
video into three sections comedy action
and changes so let's begin with our
first topic
[Music]
when tackling comedy there are certain
obstacles one most overcome and are to
be a success in the long-running show
Cadence character quirks are all things
that need to be considered this is made
even more difficult in the case of the
English dub as they are tasked to tell
the same jokes again and expect to laugh
assuming of course they think English
speakers who watched the Japanese dope
will check in for their run of the
series and you know what I think they
did expect that allow me to explain why
in a situation where FUNimation when
dubbing super could have cut Corners
they have done some wonderful extra work
with a dialogue comedically for the
series every joke if the need arises is
tweaked to suit English audiences on top
of that dotted throughout the series are
extra jokes for those on their second
trip around just give me a little time
to put this into action okay please can
you do that
ugh
Super Saiyan please and I think many of
you would agree that listening to a good
joke is great the first time around but
hearing it again never quite captures
that same feeling or response during my
initial run through the series back in
2015 there was one instance during the
first three arcs that actually made me
laugh and no it wasn't episode 5 or 24
it was this moment
it was completely absurd visual humor
that completely caught me off guard and
I still love it to this day however
during my second run through using the
English dub there were numerous
instances I found myself laughing you
could at least pretend yeah sure fine
babies beerus here this is where things
get a little subjective so I'll try to
explain as best I can my theory is that
physical jokes translate much more
effectively than dialogue driven ones
when delivered through Japanese I found
while I understood the idea behind the
delivery the Japanese commonly landed
flat much more frequently than the
English did for me you've earned some
vacation time right I'm a good father
and husband
I think it's clear from the work
revealed that a lot of care and passion
went into rewriting recording and
producing this dub comedy is nuanced but
you know what is a nuanced punching
people in the face it's time to move on
to the next section
[Music]
when when watches the Japanese dub you
are 99 times out of 100 and that's a
lowballed estimate going to watch the
broadcast version the whole point of
watching the Japanese dub for many is
down to wanting to see the show at the
earliest possible convenience I
personally don't know many who hold off
for the Japanese blu-ray releases to
catch up on the series this can lead to
viewing the show in its most raw forms
episodes 5 24 and 41 are some of the
most infamous the English dub while
still retaining some of the poor
animation is utilizing the blu-ray
releases of the series with the
animation corrected to the highest
quality it will ever be so if you like
pretty pictures the English dub viewers
will be getting a better first
impression visually speaking the next
one is a pet peeve of mine and so if you
don't relate to this that's fine one
thing that annoys me when watching anime
is that during these bombastic animated
sequences or fight scenes if it's in
Japanese you might find that you wish
your eyes weren't so fixated on the only
part of the screen there isn't any
action unless you're fluent in Japanese
I can see why someone who wants to see
the action on screen might prefer the
ease of viewing the English allows shows
like Attack on Titan that are very
animation and Exposition heavy cause the
most difficulty and it leads me to
watching the episode multiple times over
to see different things however I
understand that many are not as into the
visuals as I am and want to watch purely
for the story and that's fine too next I
would like to look at and dissect two
fight scenes specifically two scenes
that I deem as being crucial to the
series as well as being great fight
scenes in their own right the first
being Vegeta vs Kaaba the master student
dynamic between Vegeta and Kaaba is
viewed as one of the cornerstones to
Vegeta's character within super
therefore this scene is vitally
important and requires the utmost care
clearly the Japanese version was loved
and appreciated by fans across the world
and so you can imagine how many were
waiting with baited breath as the
episode unfolded before them in English
the scene is divided into three sections
the warm-up the conflict and the
resolution the warm-up consists of the
initial dialogue between the two Saiyans
during the early stages of the fight
I look forward to fighting you
this serves to further get across Cava
sportsmanship and disconnects him from
Vegeta establishing the through line or
story for this confrontation the most
noteworthy change in this scene comes
during kaaba's initial flurry to Vegeta
the Japanese version simply advises him
not to get carried away both serve to
complement the end but in different ways
the English version paints Vegeta as the
teacher much more obviously however on
the other hand it could be argued that
the Japanese one is too disconnected
from the conclusion I would also like to
note that while the dialogue Remains the
Same Vegeta is clearly talking to Kaaba
in the English version as opposed to
himself in the Japanese moving on from
there the conflict of the fight is
introduced Kaaba announces that he
cannot change into a Super Saiyan to the
surprise and disappointment of Vegeta
the conflict between the two is
initially for all intensive purposes the
same however as the section progresses
there is a slight difference I would
like to draw attention to during
Vegeta's Beatdown of Kaaba he shouts
abilities I'm surprised they even let
you compete during this Beatdown I had
to commend Clifford Chapman's Kaaba as
his wincing added to how convincing the
scene was the way it's delivered comes
across as much more harsh than the
English adaptation I think moving on
from there Vegeta begins to threaten
Kaaba and his family this is where I
think the English dub steps into a
league of its own
[Music]
their status delivery of the words kill
and murder sounds so Sinister at this
stage of the fight
I'm going to hunt down and murder one by
one every last member of your family
for them it will be quick
at this point I'd also like to point out
that Dragon Ball Super's English dub
isn't as rained in as the Japanese
version this is due to their respective
time slots and stations super airs in
Japan early Saturday morning on Fuji TV
for kids and in America super airs on
Adult Swim they have literally added
swearing to the series where there was
not prior whether or not that's a good
thing I'll leave up to you I feel I
should also add at this time that
Clifford Chapin's Kaaba sounds more
convincing while Super Saiyan remember
it's his first time transforming and
he's filled with rage
foreign
[Music]
the final and most important section the
resolution there is one slight
difference which is in keeping with the
trend this dub has the final blow
Vegeta's Kaaba in his Super Saiyan blue
form in the Japanese version he simply
States never forget this pain whereas in
the English version he says remember
this pain and let it activate you the
English adaptation is more on the nose
but in saying that it's in keeping with
what the dub established earlier in the
fight I appreciate funimation's efforts
in trying to make this scene their own
while not compromising the narrative and
through line of the confrontation moving
on to the second final and quite
possibly most important scene in the
first three arcs comes during episode
39. hit versus Goku there are
differences in this scene some of which
seem to have bothered certain people so
let's have a look the first thing you'll
notice is that shiml's Goku's voice
changes slightly depending on the form
he is in so naturally he gave Super
Saiyan blue its own voice this can be a
good or a bad thing depending on your
preference I personally appreciate the
effort as I feel it helps add a more
serious feeling to a show many would
describe as sorely needing a more
serious tone the light in question
people are bothered by is shiml's
description of the Kaioken mixed with
Super Saiyan blue Super Saiyan blue is
all about power through extreme control
combining that with the calming focus of
the kaio-ken and now there's no telling
how high I can go as you've seen in my
channel I am not above scrutinizing this
show for the mistakes that it's made in
the past but this to me sounds like
people are looking for problems rather
than noticing them both of these schimel
quotes are left vague intentionally
Super Saiyan blue is all about power
through extreme control I don't think
anyone can dispute that they even had an
episode covering it I think it's the
thought of the Kaioken being associated
with a calming Focus people seem to have
a problem with however while the move is
associated with destroying your body
you'll find that every time Goku
attempts any big move aside from the
Super Saiyan transformation calmness
precedes it specifically with the
Kaioken but back to the scene shiml's
interpretation of this scene is very
different to nazawa's down to the
dialogue and even the screams and don't
worry we'll get to those but first I
want to ask what is the Kaioken
technique is it a move that shreds your
body pushing it past its limits 2 3 and
in this case 10 times over it's a
technique that when utilized puts
tremendous stress and strain on the body
in short it puts the user in extreme
pain knowing this I would like you to
listen to these two cuts of the same
scene the first in Japanese and the
second in English
[Music]
no it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
in my opinion in this instance Sean
Schimmel knocked it out of the park and
elevated the scene higher than the
Japanese version did and this is my
reasoning as I've said the Kaioken
technique shreds the body putting it
under extreme stress and pain masaka
nazawa's delivery while fantastic and
captivating didn't convey pain Sean on
the other hand let out a Battle Cry I
could only describe as throat shredding
over the course of 10 seconds he conveys
pain determination and power it is a
Battle Cry of the highest order and in
my opinion there is no comparison it is
easily in my view shiml's best scream as
Goku
[Music]
it's important to realize that the
Japanese version is capable of making
mistakes Akira Toriyama isn't the only
one driving the story anymore there are
teams of writers working on Super for
toei so mistakes will happen an example
of one is totally writing themselves
into a corner during the Future Trunks
Arc requiring a red con of the potara
fusion all I'm saying here is that if
you have issues with the English dub for
whatever reason understand that there
are just as many reasons to not like the
Japanese version also meaning the
English can Will and in my opinion
should make changes where they deem
fitting speaking of changes that were
made let's talk specific voices briefly
first up on the chopping block is Frost
the existing Japanese voice actor for
Frieza took on the role and changed
little about his approach to the
character Frost the voice of Frieza in
English is Chris Ayers and while he
doesn't tackle the role his brother Greg
Ayers does you'll accuse me of such
terrible things vados I'm so hurt this
keeps the subtle connection to Frieza
while allowing Frost to have his own
identity this is only a positive in my
eyes bottles and Champa I have mixed
feelings on I was never really a big fan
of champa's character in the Japanese to
begin with and his adaptation into
English didn't help that either battles
on the other hand I loved in Japanese
and while I love the sound of her
English voice I feel a lot of the
attitude and Sass for lack of a better
term she showed Champa was Lost in
Translation it was a vital character to
get right and might I add difficult too
it could very easily have been a
situation that yielded a boring
performance but Matthew Mercer as hit
100 works like a charm the big one that
people seem to be complaining about is
megetta's English voice actor and to
that I ask why bother the Japanese
Maguire sounds terrible and annoying in
the first place if anything the English
is fitting are you sad that he isn't
making the same made-up stupid sounds
but on top of that he only appears in a
handful of episodes loads in the entire
series I have no idea why people even
care I've given a lot of praise to the
English dub during this video however I
will say in many ways every English dub
has advantages and disadvantages going
up against their Japanese counterparts
they have the luxury of time thinking
about their scenes months in advance
knowing full well where the series will
be going whereas the Japanese dub
suffers in needing to get the episode
out on time to air so there really isn't
time for a more complex nuanced approach
and you can forget about running the
risk of losing their voice Moscow nozawa
cannot afford to lose her voice during
recording The Show Must Go On after all
however one must also take into account
that the Japanese dub solidifies itself
in the minds of many fans by getting
there first which is arguably the most
important thing I can understand fans
disliking certain English translations
of their favorite shows there can be bad
casting or boring uninspired deliveries
but I am also of the opinion one should
defend quality and effort when one sees
it and Dragon Ball Super's English dub
is one of the best I've ever heard if
you think about it what other production
team has the budget experience and
passion for a series to match
funimations with Dragon Ball super I
guess it all comes down to a combination
of what you saw first growing up and how
you like your dragon ball is Goku the
goofy hick who only cares for fighting
strong opponents or is he the
light-hearted but strong do-gooder who
wants to fight strong opponents to
defend his loved ones we are all faced
with that subbed or dubbed decision at
one point or another so don't be so
quick to judge others for their choices
as both have the potential to offer
something the other does not thank you
so much for watching
so do you wish you waited for the
English dub or are you disappointed with
how it turned out I'd love to hear your
thoughts don't forget to rate this video
And subscribe for more anime analysis
I'm trying to upload every week so don't
forget to click that Bell icon too
see you guys